whatever you think of Donald Trump when
he's Unleashed in a crowd of people he's
pretty unbelievable if you haven't seen
the tape of him ordering at McDonald's
in East Palestine treat yourself
he Wows everyone in the room again you
don't have to love Trump to know he's
really good at this and it's real I mean
he feels it that's why he's so good at
it so he's a huge threat but in a normal
country in a democracy you would let
voters decide whether they want him to
run the country again but no
partisan prosecutors at all levels state
and federal are trying to prevent him
from running for president again
everyone knows this no one ever says it
but it's true it's happening in Fulton
County Georgia for example prosecutors
have a grand jury going and they've put
a self-described witch on it this is the
grand jury investigating Trump for
election interference in other words for
complaining about what was clearly an
unfair election now this person is
called Emily Coors she is the four
person of the jury and she posts online
about different spells she can cast CNN
just interviewed her how'd it go we'll
let you assess watch
it's not a short list
not a short list more I mean when it
comes to 75 Witnesses like is it it's
not I assume of course it's not 75
people would you characterize it as
20-ish people
I can't say I counted
okay more than a dozen though I think
I'd heard you say in another interview
I believe so I'd be interested to know
I'm sure we will hear more from him
after after it all it all comes out I
would be happy as long as something
happens
yeah just a jury of your peers
guaranteed by the Constitution
Charlie hurt is the opinion editor of
the Washington time she joins us now I
mean I didn't even know this was allowed
I didn't know the four person whatever
that is is allowed to do scene
interviews while the grand Jerusalem
panel or doesn't this anyway what do you
make of this I'll I'll stop what's your
take on this and she was picked by the
other jurors to be the fourth the four
person so I'd hate to see the rest of
the juries
um you know this woman she's a lunatic
obviously as you point out
um but uh she's you know this is kind of
what you get with America on Tick Tock
this is to her this is all a big social
media thing uh and the fact that she's
and uh not to mention of course these
things you know grand juries are
supposed to be done in secret she's
obviously blown through all of that but
it does sort of raise all kinds of
questions well gee what else is going on
in secret if this is the sort of thing
that you wind up with but if nothing
else she's a she's a poster child for
why we should only allow people who have
jobs jobs and pay taxes sit on juries
and she's also a poster child for
avoiding online dating
all right well that is absolutely true
and I'm gonna I'm Not Gonna Take debate
on that Charlie but let me just affirm
my agreement with it but really quick
big picture what's going on here is
Democrats are using the legal system to
stop a presidential candidate from
running for president now you don't have
to love Trump or if it doesn't matter if
you believe in our system and wanted to
continue you should be outraged hair on
fire angry about this but no one's
saying anything so far as I can tell
well that's the real serious side of all
of this you know she's ridiculous and
it's easy to make fun of her but but if
you if you know think about this think
if this was an actually an actual
serious case and think if if you had
actual serious adult prosecutors
Prosecuting a serious case and and you
are the person that was facing uh you
know your life in jail and you looked up
into the jury box and you saw this
lunatic sitting in the jury box these
people make a mockery of everything we
stand for and I would argue in a lot of
ways though you know even more important
than voting in this country is the the
concept of a jury of your peers you
can't be railroaded by a bunch of people
who don't who aren't like you who don't
come from your from your society and the
idea that you would you you would have a
grand jury with people like this on it
makes a mockery of all of that
that's exactly right I mean that could
be you that is absolutely right and I
hope people think about that even people
who don't like Trump think about that
we're breaking Too Much Charlie here
thank you great to see you subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight